you know who's all about krypton is
sending shockwaves to the cryptoverse
these days
as always elon musk of course elon musk
shocker alert sending shockwaves through
the crypto world so elon musk sends the
shibu enu coin this is the coin that i
was struggling with plummeting and he
basically says true value is in building
products respect what story is this
okay it's an entrepreneur you have it uh
no
it's what's it called what's the
headline
um you're looking at the doc
no i'm not
all right what's the what's the headline
entrepreneur oh elon musk sends shibuya
coin plummeting gotcha okay
so basically he says um
[Music]
keep going basically in one word he
basically dismantled chibuino at least
for the time being so a twitter account
that was basically apropos aptly named
shibu inu holder he asked must how much
shibu you own elon
and in one word he responded
none
zero
um and then right after that tank it
went down seven percent because he's on
dogecoin
yes he basically says thank you that's a
great segue he says look i own bitcoin
ethereum and dogecoin aka the doge
father and he basically warned his
followers or warned anybody that would
listen not to bet the farm on crypto so
as someone that is that big on crypto
he's also saying don't bet the farm on
crypto i know a lot of people that are
all in on crypto quote unquote elon musk
says true value is building products and
providing services for your fellow human
beings
not money in any form aka
shibuya just money in a form okay yeah
so
um
elon is basically saying your whole life
shouldn't be just based on crypto
because i know a lot of people like that
it'd be this is just elon spinning game
yeah okay
um
you know one of the things that
if you're if you're focusing on crypto
you know they say i like crypto because
it's decentralized it's decentralized
decentralized you can't you know can't
it's not centralized you know where it
is centralized on elon musk's twitter
platform that's dude on his twitter feed
that guy that guy moves we talked about
tom brady being able to move markets
because he wants to get paid in bitcoin
whatever i always elon musk with a tweet
divorce dogecoin plummeting or shibu inu
plummeting or bitcoin on the rise that's
he's got that much pull yeah that's why
when you asked me would you want to be
paid in bitcoin hey it's kind of dodgy
it's uh elon musk could say yeah
anything we talk as money
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken